تحت عنوان اصوات الضحايا المكتومه في غزه
قال تحليل لصحيفه ليبراسيون انه بحرمان
الصحافه الاجنبيه من الوصول الى قطاع غزه
واجبار الصحافه المحليه على العمل في ظروف
مروعه فرضت اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
تعتيماً صرح فيليب لازاريني المفوض العام
لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين اونروا لصحيفه
فاينانشال تايمز ان القضاء على الاونروا
اصبح احد اهداف الحرب الاسرائيليه وانه
مستمر في منصبه ما دامت الوكاله قادره على
دعم الناس وايصال صوت اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين وقال لازاريني ان الاونر تاخذ
على محمل الجد المزاعم بشان تورط موظفين
لديها في هجوم السابع من اكتوبر لكن ان
اسرائيل لم تقدم دليلا عليها واضاف ربما
ندفع ثمن ارتفاع صوتنا في لفت الانتباه
الى محنه سكان غزه والكارثه الانسانيه
التي تتكشف امام اعيننا قالت صحيفه
التليغراف ان تحليلا اجرته لصور فضائيه
اظهر تدمير اسرائيل اكثر من الف مبنى في
المناطق الحدوديه لقطاع غزه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر واوضحت ان الصور تظهر خطا واضحا في
بعض المنا ناطق التي دمرت بعرض كيلومتر
على الاقل خلف السياج الامني الفاصل بين
اراضي اسرائيل والقطاع المحاصر وتتهم
اسرائيل بالسعي لانشاء منطقه عازله داخل
قطاع غزه بطول الحدود بما يؤدي الى تاكل
مساحه القطاع وذلك رغم المعارضه الواضحه
من حلفاء اسرائيل في الغرب قالت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز ان وجود المتظاهرين
الغاضبين في حرب اسرائيل على غزه امام مقر
اقامه وزير الخارج الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
شمال فيرجينيا بات منتظما اذا اعتصم بعضهم
لعده ايام في الشوارع ونصبوا الخيام
وتابعت الصحيفه ان الاعلام الفلسطينيه
واللافتات عبرت عن غضب المتظاهرين من اداء
بلينكن وموقف الاداره الامريكيه من الحرب
على غزه ختاما تحدثت صحيفه لوفيجارو عن
تاخر انتقام جو بايدن لمقتل جنود امريكيين
في الاردن وقالت ان احد التفسيرات
موقف الانتظار والترقب ربما يكمن في
المفاوضات الحساسه الجاريه حاليا بين
اسرائيل وحركه حماس ولن يؤدي تصعيد العنف
الا لزياده صعوبه اختتام المحادثات التي
يقال انها تسير على الطريق الصحيح نحو وقف
القتال حسب
[موسيقى]
الصحيفه